[Applause]
how are you i'm so happy to see you
oh natalie and then as you come on the
screen i'm like oh my god and
the dior like fantasy all of a sudden
i'm hit with those peter phillips red
lips
oh thank you well i'm so happy i can't
believe i was like tearing up
listening to you talking about me
because i was like i grew up with you
and then i got to when we got to work
together it was such an amazing
amazing experience for me and so
exciting for me
i remember that so so fondly like i
remember
so many details of like being like 13 in
the
back or maybe 14 14 or 15 in the
bathroom at the premiere together and
feeling like so grown up
you know i'm i'm reading about you and i
i read this thing about how
you know you didn't have an easy time in
school because you would go
out to movies and then you would come
back and just have an
awkward time with like other kids at the
school and i i haven't really read that
from a lot of people and that was
totally my experience i
really related to that i mean i think
people get bullied for all sorts of
reasons and i guess that's a lucky
reason to get to be bullied for
because you're doing something that you
love and i mean if you're doing
something that you love
um you know i do think that that's sort
of what like
creates your empathy exactly like
like getting being on that side of the
the teasing certainly makes you never
want to make anyone feel like that ever
again
well and the irony is they would always
say to me you think you're so special
and i really read that in what you said
in the copy and i'm like
oh my gosh that's exactly what they
would say to me and
i was like i not only don't think i'm
special but you are
absolutely confirming i am not
i know it's so sad and it's so it's also
so like you know young people should be
able to be proud of their
accomplishments and i was like oh god i
should just
keep my head down all the time which
isn't a way to go through life either
but then you were also voted in high
school most likely to
appear on jeopardy
yes i was like the biggest uh biggest
nerd
at school i was like known for always
having like my hands covered and white
out
and like being in all the dorky classes
so
hashtag hot nerd um
[Laughter]
you you you complimented the the
headphone out of my ear thank you
well you know we're all trying to
challenge ourselves
in our own ways but i love that you are
known to
have said that you were not willing to
give up an education in order to
remain an actress or be in your job that
it was worth the risk for you to step
aside
and seek out a harvard education i have
so much respect for that
yeah i don't it was funny because i
don't know that it was really like a
it didn't feel like such a big choice to
me i feel like it i only became aware
that it was like a choice when
um people started asking me about it in
interviews like
in my family it was so like you just go
to college you just
that's something you do um but i'm so
glad i i did it
um you are so like
you're the hot nerd you're smart you're
well read you're
worldly you're invested in things um
you're just such a aware person and then
i love
um last night i'm so proud to tell you
natalie
um and you're such a good mom and i know
you work with children's hospital
um which is such an important
vital institution and i was reading
your book to my daughters last night and
we read all three stories and this is
our copy
and i know that gender
and mixing that up and bringing sort of
a new generation of gender awareness
and um kind of getting out of the
stereotypical roles that we think of
with fairy tales
and as i was reading the book i was
doing a male voice for the tortoise
and my daughter olive said mom you're
doing a male voice for the tortoise but
it said the tortoise was a female
i love it i i really like
appreciate that um you're sharing it
with your kids that makes me so excited
and um and yeah it's uh
i wanted to write the book to uh
make more characters of different
genders
that kids can relate to i think it's how
we develop empathy is reading
caring about characters watching tv or
movies like we spend time with the
characters we feel their feelings
and i was noticing in all my kind of
classic kids books
that the characters were almost all male
even in the animal kingdom which of
course
that's not how it is in nature so um i
set out to retell some of the classic
stories because i
didn't want to throw out these stories
that i grew up with that my parents had
read me that had been passed down from
generation to generation
but i wanted to um be able to do
something that
um you know that that represents the
the world as it is gender was and
um allows kids male and female
characters to
relate to i i really love this book and
i think
your writing is just extraordinary and
that's something i
i value so much and as such an amazing
reader as you are i love your instagram
posts the consistency
of that with all your books and actually
i'd really love to turn to general
larson who's someone
who he and i have a very shared
philosophy that books
are available to people and there's
something that we all have the ability
to educate
ourselves from he he would love to
review your book if that's okay
oh thank you that is amazing a huge
honor
he is just the most wonderful
book-loving young gentleman and i can't
wait to bring him in
um and uh so we're gonna go to a quick
commercial
and when we come back um jonah larson
but quick sidebar by the way
when it comes to gender roles i totally
agree with you
and that's why i wanted to go out and
make like a charlie's angels and have
women get to do what boys do
and i don't think that there's anything
i'm anticipating as much
in this world and in this life as you as
thor
oh thank you aye very exciting
well when you went to comic-con and held
that
up and that photo went i mean just since
that day i've been waiting to see you do
this so
i can't wait